PROFESSOR: We are thundering
rapidly to the
midpoint of the term.
I think a week from this
coming Thursday will be
exactly halfway, and the
halfway point is when I
usually try, give or take a
day, to change gears very
abruptly and start looking at
the symmetry of physical
properties and tensors and
actual discussion of physical
properties that are
anisotropic.
So we'll be finishing
up our discussion of
symmetry fairly quickly.
We still have, however, some
major derivations to perform,
and we'll get into one
of these today.
Last time we had begun the
process of deriving what are
called the point groups as
opposed to the plane groups.
The plane groups were
combinations of symmetry with
a lattice that extended
throughout a plane in space.
A point group we've seen in the
form of two-dimensional
point groups.
We're now going to today derive
the three-dimensional
point groups.
And, again, the name stems from
the fact that these are
clusters of symmetry about a
common point so that at very
least that one point
in space stays put.
So, hence, point groups--
these are symmetries
about a point.
And to put some embellishing
adjectives on here, these will
be the three-dimensional
crystallographic point groups.
Because there are an infinite
number of point groups, we're
considering just those
symmetries that can be
combined with a lattice
and therefore are
permissible to crystals.
I'd like to point out in case
you've not been making much
use of Buerger's book that we
actually are getting back to
Buerger's treatment.
We'll do some of the derivations
over the next few
days with a little bit more
detail and with a slightly
different procedure
than Buerger.
But the bases covered
are the same.
So let me just point out where
some of this material is in
Buerger's book.
Buerger does Euler's
Construction, and he does this
in a once over lightly.
I think this is not the
best part of the book.
This is on pages 35 to 43.
In particular, he sort of leaps
ahead quickly and just
looks for one angle between
rotation axes and doesn't get
the-- do specifically the ones
that are 90 degrees and are
not as interesting.
Some of the combination theorems
are in Chapter 6, and
there you'll find the statement
that two reflections
at an angle mu is equivalent
to a net rotation of mu,
except Buerger doesn't
call them sigmas.
He calls them m's.
He uses the same symbol for
individual operations and for
the symmetry of them, and I
think that's a little untidy.
Also, the theorem that says that
if we have a mirror plane
that's perpendicular to a
twofold rotation axis, that
gives rise to inversion center
at the point of intersection.
And then he launches into a
rather condensed version of
the derivation of the point
groups on pages 59 to 68.
Then, in Chapter 7, derives the
two dimensional lattices
or the plane nets.
This is on page 69 to 83.
We've done that differently and
much more exhaustively by
deriving the two-dimensional
plane groups and the lattices
are part of the plane groups,
and we've gotten them
automatically.
There is a place where in the
derivation of the space
lattices, he's a little bit
incomplete and actually does
something that's wrong A-ha--
I showed Buerger was wrong
at one place in his book.
But anyway, this is where the
material that we're covering
now is mentioned in
Buerger's book.
Last time, we had hit
a new surprise.
We had asked if we take the
basic rotational symmetries
and add an inversion to
something like three--
so, three is a subgroup,
the operation of
inversion is an extender.
We found that there was a new
operation that came up, and
this was a rotoinversion
operation.
And then the resulting point
group, which we called 3-bar--
the symbol itself, 3-bar, is
a threefold rotoinversion.
And if we were not clever
enough to invent a
rotoinversion operation, we
would have stumbled headlong
over it in adding inversion
as an extender
to a threefold axis.
And a rotoinversion axis is
something that involves in
general rotating through some
angle alpha to get from a
first object to a second object
of the same handedness
and then not yet putting it
down, first inverting it
through axis--
through a point on the axis--
to get a second object.
I shouldn't call this second
because this is not rotation
with inversion simultaneously
but a two step operation.
So we rotate from 1 to this
virtual object also of same
handedness and then before
putting it down, we invert it
to get number two, which
is left handed.
And the operation of getting
there in two steps but in one
repetition is the operation
of rotoinversion.
That operation was one of the
members of the group that
results when you add inversion
as an extender to 3.
But, really, this was not
something that was a new sort
of symmetry element.
It was an operation that came
up, but we could regard the
point down that we've labeled
3-bar as simply a threefold
axis with an inversion
center sitting on it.
But then we looked
at another one.
And by anticipation, I said
we ought to look at these.
And we looked at what happened
when we took a fourfold
rotoinversion operation where we
would take the first object
number one, rotate it through
90 degrees, and
not yet put it down.
We'd first invert it through a
point on an axis, and we got
one that was 90 degrees away
but pointing down in of
opposite handedness.
If we repeated that operation
several times, we found that
we got two objects up above a
plane normal to the rotation
part of the operation and
passing through the point,
which we inverted.
So there's one right handed one
up here, a second right
handed one up here, and then two
down below, which were of
opposite chirality,
number 3 and 4.
And that is an entirely
new beast.
We have no way of describing
the relation between these
four objects other than saying
rotate, don't put it down,
first invert.
Rotate, don't put it down,
first invert again.
So this is something
entirely new.
It's a two step operation.
You cannot describe it any more
simply than saying take
two steps to do the repetition
in the same sense that the
glide plane that we discovered
in the plane groups had a step
of translation followed
immediately by reflection, and
that was a new sort
of operation.
So here's another example
of a two-step operation.
The symbol for this point group
is 4-bar, and the symbol
for it-- if you want to indicate
its locus, is, it's
got a squareness to it because
these objects as mutually are
separated by 90 degrees, but it
really has only a twofold
symmetry, so the symmetry
for a 4-bar axis.
It's not really an
axis at all.
It's a 4-bar point,
because only a
point is left invariant.
But the symbol for a 4-bar
"axis" is this square with a
little twofold axis
inscribed in it.
Alright.
We ought to really, then, step
back and ask how many
different rotoinversion axes
there might be, and add these
to our bags of tricks.
And what I'm going to invite you
to do is to examine this
systematically on a problem set
which I will pass around,
along with several other
problems for your
consideration, as well.
And having stumbled onto that
combination, another thing we
might ask to broaden our bag of
tricks still further is to
say is there such a thing as
a rotoreflection axis?
And we called n-bar
a rotoinversion.
I wrote a reflection axis is
indicated by an n with this
little squiggle on top.
Anyone who has studied Spanish
realizes that the proper name
for the squiggle is a
tilde, T-I-L-D-E.
And this would be an operation
where there's a locus in which
we'll perform the reflection
part of the operation, so this
would be a 2 step operation that
involves taking a first
one and rotating it to a virtual
object number two but
not putting it down.
Before putting it down, we will
reflect in a planar locus.
So this is number two, and it
will be of opposite chirality.
So that's another operation that
involves rotation coupled
as one part of a step that
involves R, the second of our
three translation free
operations, namely reflection
and inversion.
So are these something
we should consider?
What I've invited you to do is
to draw out for n equals 1 to
8 the patterns produced by
rotoinversion and the patterns
created by rotoreflection, and
then see if you regard these
as new operations or whether
they can be broken down into
the simultaneous presence of
more than one of our old
friends such as 3-bar being a
plain old threefold axis with
an inversion sitting on it.
The fact that I'm asking you
take your time to do this
suggests that yes, you are
going to find some
rotoinversion and rotoreflection
axes, which are
inherently 2 step operations
and can't be decomposed.
What I'd like to do now, then,
is to systematically look at
the axial combinations.
These are of the form n one,
two, three, four, and six and
the dihedral symmetries.
These are of the form n22, or
just 32 in the case of the one
with the threefold axis.
And then the two cubic
arrangements 23, twofold axis
out of the face normal to a
cube, threefold axes out of
all of the body diagonals,
and 432.
And what I'm going to do with
you is to use these as
worksheets to guide the logic
of what we're doing, and we
won't do every single
one of them.
I think once we do a few, the
general principle is clear and
the results there
are before you.
But what we'll take, then, is
the axes n, the axes n22, and
then the two cubic symmetries
23 and 432.
Then, finally, we found 4-bar
as a different rotation
axis-like symmetry element, so
I'll add that to the list.
Then consider what we can add
to these symmetries as
extenders, and these are an
additional element that we can
add to what is already a
self-contained nice little group.
We muck things up by introducing
another operation,
and then we'll have to take
combinations of that operation
with all the symmetry elements
that are there in the parent
subgroup and see what new
symmetry elements arise.
The ground rules in these
additions are fairly simple
but nevertheless profound.
The addition of the extender
cannot create any new symmetry
axes by its operation, and the
reason for that should be
quite clear.
We obtained these combinations
of rotation axes using Euler's
principle, and that was
thorough and orderly,
systematic and complete.
These are the only
arrangements of
crystallographic rotation
axes that are possible.
So if we add an extender that
creates, for example, a new
twofold axis in n22, it's either
going to be something
that we already have in this
list, and therefore not
interesting, or something
that just cannot
constitute a group.
We'll take combinations of
operations and we will never
find a closed finite set.
So if we add a mirror operation,
a reflection
operation as an extender, the
addition of the reflection
operation sigma must be either
perpendicular to the axis.
And what that's going to do is
just flip the top part of the
rotation axis and reflect it
down to the bottom axis.
Nothing new was created.
And it could alternatively be
parallel to the axis and
passing through it.
In that case, we've already seen
the consequences of this
addition in deriving the
two-dimensional point groups,
namely to 2mm, 3m,
4mm, and 6mm.
No new axis is created.
One of the additions that is
something we mentioned last
time is that in the case of the
dihedral groups where we
have an n-fold axis and
then twofold axes
arranged in some fashion--
not in some arbitrary fashion.
It's going to be 2 pi over n
times 1/2, depending on the
n-fold axis--
we could pass the
mirror operation
through the twofold axis.
And that's what we'll call
a vertical mirror plane.
But when there's more than one
axis present, we could also
put the reflection operation
diagonally in between the
twofold axes.
So we're going to refer to this
as a diagonal mirror.
It's snaked in between the
axes that are present.
So, perpendicular reflection
operation as an extender, one
parallel to the axis and passing
through it, or one
that is diagonal passing
in between them.
And finally, that exhausts
what we can do with
reflection, but we could
add inversion.
And if we're not going create
new axes, and we're going to
get a point group-- a finite
set of objects--
the inversion center has to be
on one of the single axis,
namely these groups n, or at the
point of intersection, if
there's more than one.
So there's the job
laid out for us.
And we've got two theorems to
aid us in quickly finding the
new operations that arise--
in effect, taking a shortcut
to establish the group
multiplication table, and the
two theorems are as follows.
We saw that if you take a
rotation operation A pi, that
takes a first object that's
right handed and rotates it to
a second object that is
also right handed.
Then follow that by reflection
in a mirror plane that is
perpendicular to the axis.
The net effect of going from 1
to number 3, which is left
handed, is to create an
inversion center at the point
of intersection.
So there's a theorem that we
can write down once and for
all and say that A pi followed
by reflection in a mirror
plane that's perpendicular to
axis A has, as a net effect,
the operation of inversion.
And if this is not a twofold
axis, it's something like a
fourfold axis or a sixfold
axis, that contains the
operation A pi as part of the
operations contained in that
axis, and that's going
to create an
inversion center as well.
So for any evenfold axis, add a
perpendicular mirror plane,
and automatically the inversion
center comes up.
And we can permute the order
of these operations if we
rotate by 180 degrees and then
invert the net effect is
reflection in the perpendicular
mirror plane.
So this is something that you
permute around into three
different combinations.
Does the order of the operation
make a difference?
And the answer is no, the
order is not important.
For example, rotating and then
reflecting is the same as
reflecting and then
rotating it.
It went up at the same
point, number 3.
Remember a fancy word for this
when we define what's meant by
a group, that these groups are
going to be what's called
Abelian, and an Abelian group
is where any combination of
operations a followed by b is
identical to b followed by a.
I told you that great joke among
mathematicians, what is
purple and commutes?
And the answer is an
Abelian grape.
Ha, ha, ha--
I think that's stupid, but it
drives mathematicians into
guffaws of laughter.
A second theorem, and this is
one that we've already seen in
two dimensions, is that if you
take an operation A alpha,
pass a reflection operation
sigma 1 through it, that to
the effect of that is going to
be another mirror plane that
is alpha over 2 away
from the first.
Notice I'm a little bit sloppy
in talking about reflection
operation and mirror plane
because if a reflection
operation is there, that's all
I need to have to say that
this is the locus of a symmetry
point, a mirror plane.
So this is another one.
Do you think that this an
Abelian combination to say
that A alpha followed by sigma
1 is equal to sigma 2.
Is this Abelian?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, it's not.
And how do you answer that?
Not through any means more
profound than just drawing it
out and seeing what you get.
Let's take 3n as an example.
So let's do the operation.
In this order, do the rotation
A 2 pi over 3 to go from this
one up to this one, and then
let's reflect across this
horizontal mirror plane.
So this is 1 right handed,
this is 2 right handed
reflect, here's number three
and it's left handed.
So that's A 2 pi over
3 followed by
reflection in sigma 1.
And if we do the operations in
reverse order, reflect in
sigma 1 to go up to here, so
this would be 2 prime and then
rotate by 120 degrees.
We would go to here to here,
and that is not the same
location as this one.
So this is not equal to sigma
1 followed by A 2 pi over 3.
How can you tell when is the
combination of operations is
going to be Abelian and
when is it not?
It sounds rather clumsy to
state it in words, but
whenever the two symmetry
operations leave each other
unmoved, then you can
permute the order.
For example, in this combination
here the rotation
leaves the mirror
plane unchanged.
It just spins around
in its own plane.
The mirror plane leaves the
rotation unchanged, it just
reflects it end to end.
Here this rotation axis and
these mirror planes obviously
do not leave each other
unchanged because the
threefold axis rotates
the mirror plane to
two other new locations.
So whenever that's the case, if
the operations do not leave
each other unchanged, the order
makes a difference.
So that's a useful thing
to keep in mind.
Let's now turn to these sheets
that I passed out, and you
might want to unstaple them
because they're designed to go
side by side, and there
are three pages.
What I've done across the top
of the pages is to give the
different combinations of
crystallographic rotation axes
that are possible.
So going from the first sheet
across to the last, there's
the rotation axes
by themselves--
one, two, three,
four, and six.
Then there are the groups of
the form n22, 222, 32, 422,
622, and then the two cubic
combinations 23 and 432.
So there are the 11 possible
combination of
crystallographic rotation axes,
and stuck off by itself
at the end is the
oddball 4-bar.
For the axes by themselves, the
diagonal mirror addition
is not defined.
The diagonal mirror position
by definition snakes in
between axes that are there
in the axial combination.
If there's only one axis,
that's not defined.
But you could add a horizontal
mirror plane.
A horizontal mirror planes
adds a onefold axis.
It's just a mirror plane.
So that's called m in
the international
notation for mirror.
And it's called C sub S, C
because it's a cyclic group,
and the S stands for Spiegel.
That's the Schoenflies
notation.
If we add a--
take two and add a horizontal
mirror plane--
this is the thing that we
sketched out here--
this gives a pattern of four
objects, two that are up above
the mirror plane of one
chirality, two down below the
mirror plane of opposite
chirality.
These projections of the
patterns are down along the
rotation axis, and when you
see a dot in a circle, the
circle represents the point that
is down and the dot is
one that's up on top.
So there are two pairs
of objects--
two right handed ones that are
up and two left-handed ones
that are down.
And that, in international
notation, is 2/m the twofold
axis is over a mirror plane.
So that's the way to make
sense of the symbol and
remember what it means.
In the Schoenflies
notation at C2.
You've added a horizontal mirror
plane as an extender.
Going down the remaining ones
in that list because they're
all very, very similar--
add a mirror plane to a
threefold axis, the triangle
is reflected down to a triangle
of motifs of opposite
chirality, so that's 3 over m.
For sure, it's called 6-bar, but
let's forget about that.
The Schoenflies notation C3H,
and similarly there's a 4 over
m, a square above, and a square
of opposite handedness
below the mirror plane.
The horizontal mirror plane in
all of these cases is shown as
a bold line.
They've added fainter vertical
lines to give
you an angular reference.
Don't be confused by that
in the Xerox copy--
the weight of the lines
is not distinguished.
So the only symmetry element
in 4 over m, for example,
should be shown by this solid
bold circle that is in the
plane of the paper.
The two crossed lines are
lighter and those are just as
mutual orientations.
And finally, there's another
one of this form
which is 6 over m.
On all of the evenfold
additions-- that is, to say
everything but 3m--
if you add that horizontal
mirror plane, it's going to be
perpendicular to an
operation A pi.
Therefore, inversion pops up
as one of the operations in
the group, and 2 over m, 4
over m, 6 over m, those
regular polyhedra of objects--
can be inverted through the
point of intersection of the
axis in the mirror plane, and
that leaves the set unchanged.
So if we go down to the bottom
of the list and say, can we
add inversion to these axial
arrangements, in the case of
2, 4, and 6--
no, adding inversion doesn't
give you anything new, because
that's already there in the
groups of the form CNH, or
2/m, 4/m, 6/m.
Diagonal is not defined, so the
only additional one that
we could pick up by adding
inversion is adding inversion
to a threefold axis,
and that's one we
did the other day.
Adding inversion to a threefold
axis gives us three
that are up of one handedness,
three that are down of
opposite handedness, and
the orientation of
the triangle is skewed.
That is called 3-bar.
But it's just nothing more than
a threefold axis with an
inversion center
sitting on it.
Schoenflies' notation is C3i.
Then the only other additions to
the single axes are adding
the mirror plane in a vertical
fashion passing through the
axis, and these we've already
seen in two dimensions so we
don't have to spend
much time on them.
There's 2 mm, which is C2V.
3m--
all the mirror planes result
upon adding a single mirror
plane to the threefold axis--
4 mm, and 6 mm.
These are just three-dimensional
extensions
parallel to the axis of the
symmetry that we already
derived for a plane
in space in the
two-dimensional point groups.
So we're almost half done.
It's easy, isn't it?
Any questions at this point?
So the only ones that are really
new that we haven't
seen already in two dimensions
are the rotation axis
perpendicular to the
mirrored plane.
That brings us to roughly the
middle of the second sheet,
and the arrangement of axes 222
represents three mutually
orthogonal twofold axes.
If we add a horizontal mirror
plane, that's going to put an
inversion center at the point
of intersection because that
horizontal reflection is going
to be sitting normal to a
twofold axis.
And then since the other twofold
axes see an inversion
center sitting on it, there's
a mirror plane perpendicular
to those other twofold axes.
So adding again to go through
that again, adding inversion
to the point of intersection of
the twofold axes creates a
mirror plane perpendicular to
each of those twofold axes.
So it becomes 2/m 2/m 2/m--
each of the twofold axes
acquires a different sort of
mirror plane perpendicular
to its orientation.
And 2/m 2/m 2/m, even though
I love saying it,
is kind of a mouthful.
So that's very often abbreviated
to just mmm, which
really is a nice exclamation
when you see what a lovely
symmetry it is.
The pattern shown in the diagram
to the left is just
the pattern of 222 with the
objects reflected up or
reflected down, and you
get a total of 8.
That means that there are eight
operations in the group,
and you can add up quickly
what they are.
They are the three operations
of rotating by pi, the
operation of identity, then
three mirror planes because
the mirror planes all
indistinct, and then the
operation of inversion.
So there are the eight
operations that are present
that generate the objects
from a single one.
Add a horizontal mirror plane to
32 and you get a threefold
axis perpendicular to the
threefold axis, so you write
that as 3m.
That mirror plane now passes
through the horizontal twofold
axes, and a twofold axis with a
mirror plane passing through
it wants another mirror plane
90 degrees away, so a new
mirror plane pops up passing
through each of the twofold
axes and perpendicular to the
horizontal mirror plane.
Those mirror planes are
in the same direction
as the twofold axis.
They're not perpendicular to it,
and when symmetry elements
are parallel to a common
direction you write them out
on the same line, so here's a
case of a mixed metaphor.
One mirror plane that's
perpendicular to an axis, the
threefold axis, so you write
that as 3 over m.
The other twofold axes have
mirror points passing through
them, so you write that as 2m
and the threefold axes makes
all of those 2m symmetries
equivalent to one another.
Pattern, and this is true for
all of these symmetries, is
nothing more than the pattern
of the subgroup repeated by
the one operation that you've
added as an extender .
So if you look at the pattern of
32, object all of the same
chirality, all apparently
up and down, and add the
horizontal mirror plane.
The one that is up goes down,
the one that's down goes up,
and you get a set of
four around each
of the twofold axes.
422 behaves very similarly.
The pattern is just the pattern
of 422 reflected in a
plane, so you have a
set of 16 objects--
eight of them up of one
chirality, those are the solid
dots, if you will, and then
another two, four, six, eight
that are down of opposite
chirality.
You have a mirror plane that
you added as the horizontal
mirror plane perpendicular
to the fourfold axis.
All of the horizontal twofold
axes see a mirror plane
passing through them.
So they've got to have a mirror
plane that's 90 degrees
away, and those are the vertical
mirror planes.
Either the point is obvious now
or you're not following me
at all, so I'll simply say on
the left-hand column of the
final sheet, 622 with a
horizontal mirror plane goes
to 6/m, 2/m, 2/m, called
D6h in Schoenflies.
I'll leave the cubic
ones until last.
They're not nearly as
bad as they seem.
But obviously they have a lot
of symmetry all over the
place, and we'll want to take a
closer look at the patterns.
The next extender is a vertical
mirror plane, and
we've already got the groups of
the form cnv, because they
are just extensions in a third
dimension of one set we've
seen in two dimensions.
If we try adding the vertical
mirror plane, which is defined
as passing through the principal
axis of high
symmetry and perpendicular to
the twofold axes, we've
already encountered those in
every group except 32.
2/m, 2/m, 2/m already has the
vertical mirror plane.
The same is true of 3/mm2.
The same is true of 4/m, 2/m,
2/m and 6/m, 2/m, 2/m.
The vertical mirror plane comes
in automatically when we
add the horizontal mirror plane
as the extender, So
nothing new there at all.
And now we come to one
that is interesting.
This is the diagonal
mirror plane.
And I'll do this one slowly
and then in some detail
because it's another example
of how we would trip over
something if we were not clever
enough to think of it.
Let me begin by drawing the
three orthogonal axes of 222.
So we have one object that's up
and one object that's down.
The twofold axis perpendicular
to the board will take this
one that's down and rotate it
to here and take this one
that's up and rotate
it to here.
So that is the pattern of 222.
We can snake a mirror plane in
between the twofold axes, and
a mirror plane passing through
the vertical twofold axis has
to be accompanied by one that's
90 degrees away, half
the throw of the axis, which
comes from our theorem that
says A pi dot sigma vertical
has to be equal to a sigma
prime that's vertical and pi/2
away from the first.
In terms of the pattern, this
second mirror plane that comes
up is going to reflect this one
across to here, it's going
to reflect this one across to
here, it's going to take this
one and reflect it over to here,
and take this one and
reflect it to the
right, as well.
So now we've got a total
of eight objects.
This one is right handed, and
this one is also right handed
because we repeated
it by rotation.
Then we reflected that pair, so
these two are left handed,
and reflect it across the other
diagonal mirror plane.
They're back to right handed
again, and these have to be
left handed as well, so
there's the pattern.
Is there an inversion center
in this pattern?
The answer is no, because there
is no mirror plane that
is perpendicular to a twofold
axis, so this point group has
no inversion in it.
It's said to be acentric,
without a inversion center.
Do we know how everything is
related to everything else?
We know how this one
is related to this
one by twofold rotation.
We know how this one is related
to this one, and
that's by reflection across
the mirror plane.
How is the first one related
to this one?
How do you get it through 90
degrees and then pop it down
and change the chirality?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You can't do
that in one step.
You've got to do just what
I said in words.
Rotate it 90 degrees, don't put
it down yet, and reflect
it down in a horizontal
mirror plane.
This horizontal mirror plane
is not a symmetry element,
it's part of the operation
that's necessary to get us
from this guy over to this guy
of opposite chirality.
So this is an example
a new type of
operation, a 2 step operation.
This is a 90-degree
rotoreflection axis.
And again, I feel compelled to
put the axis in quotation
marks, because really it's a
pair of operations that leaves
only a point unmoved,
so it's really a
point symmetry element.
There's another way of
describing the same thing, and
that would be rotoinversion.
We could rotate by 90 degrees in
the reverse sense, not yet
put it down, and invert,
and we get, again,
the relation between--
what did I do?
Rotate it here, yes--
rotate to here and then invert,
and we got that one.
So that's another way of
defining the relation.
A 90-degree rotoreflection
is a minus 90-degree
rotoinversion.
So you pays your money and you
takes your choice, and what
the groundbreakers who went
before us did was to take
rotoinversion.
as the operation to survive.
So here is, if we were not smart
enough to invent it, our
4-bar rotoinversion axis.
So if we hadn't been clever
enough-- and it would take a
pretty clever, devious mind to
invent a 2 step rotoinversion
operation--
as soon as we added this sort of
extender, a diagonal mirror
plane to a group of the form
n22, we would have found that
there was a new sort of
transformation that could not
be described any more simply
than to say take
two steps to do it.
Rotate 90 degrees
and then invert.
So we have to add the operation
of A pi over 2-bar
to our basic bag of tricks
for generating patterns.
The group 32 is also a group to
which we can add a diagonal
mirror plane.
And if you do that, again, the
bold lines that are mirror
planes in that group and the
axes that are faint lines are
easy to mix up.
But if we examine that group
without the confusing lines,
here are the twofold axes.
And remember that they are all
equivalent to one another by
the threefold axis.
So this axial group
is the group 32.
If we put down a mirror plane
interleaved between the
twofold axes, notice that
each of those mirror is
perpendicular to
a twofold axis.
So we can write this as 2/m.
2/m means there's an inversion
center at the intersection of
the twofold axes with
the mirror planes.
And a inversion center sitting
on a threefold axis makes it a
3-bar axis, so this group
is called 3-bar 2/m.
And the pattern is what a
twofold axis would do.
These would be up-down-right
ones.
Reflect those and you get an
up-down pair of left ones.
Reflect again and you get
an up-down pair of
right-handed ones.
Reflect yet again, and you
get an up-down pair
of left-handed ones.
Reflect still once more, and
you get a down-up pair of
right-handed ones.
One more time, up-down
left-handed ones.
So you get a total of 2,
4, 6, 8, 10, 12 points.
So this is 3-bar 2/m in
Schoenflies notation D3--
that's the symbol 32--
with a diagonal mirror
plane added.
You indicate that by a
d in the subscript.
OK.
I think that's probably a point
where you're more than
ready for a break.
We've got very few yet to do.
One surprise is that if you add
diagonal mirror planes to
422 and 622, you get perfectly
lovely exquisite groups but
they're not crystallographic,
so we don't
include them in our list.
But we'll discuss them when we
come back, and then take a
look also at the cubic
symmetries.
Impossible to draw, but really
not all that difficult to
understand.
So let's stop at this point
and take a stretch.
People are stretching already.
They need it.
We'll resume in 10
minutes' time.